はぁ
jr
みなさんこんにちは
今日は豊橋技術科学大学で私たち半導体をやってるスタッフポッパー10名でスタート
したんですが
どのように ic 抽選回路やセンサーの研究そして
世界にもまれなるその研究環境ができたかというのを私の3つも挑戦とミット境遇と
いうことでまとめてお渡しできればというふうに思います
1900台19で私が濃く人
ちょうど
第五期勢が研究室に来た4年生二年目ですね
でそこで初代学長の作家企業で一応先生です
ミンファの前で
88番目の国立大学としてできたんですでは大きい大学と同じことをやっていては88
番メンディだ
至極当然で非常にわかりやすい
この言葉は私の中にずっとありまして
三つ子の魂100バレー
私を連想ワードあんまよ
するときにこの言葉からいつもストラップしていた
そして当時日本は半導体
王国でたくさんの ic をつくって売ってましたが大学では教育
永久に
ちりこ絵レーサーいいお
扱うことはできませんですそういう後で言いますよ
そこで私たちは日本で本格的なシリコンへレーザー愛の教育天宮いいと16ことにず
タータしたら
どこ大学の先生をそれをやりたいと思ってたんですが
it を扱うということは号何だおかあ年ポニー感とロールを必要とすごい
教育は非常にんですが
私たち研究の政府まあ今でも新聞でいきますので
日本あの角が出てきたっ
角だけじゃないんですけどやっぱり数もない
そうしますと効率の悪いいうことになればいい
しかし私たちは ic と戦争を一緒
くっさー
センサーを一緒にするといろんな開いておいでている
微細化ダメだったらいい
いうことでスタートしたんですがちょうど今の時代4充電買って iot という相手
のまさに
最初
高価な ic いいの設備を新品て通う理由は耐えれないって
ちょうど私の上司にあたる中原て pro
の
aec というまあ読んでいくというねえねえ c から人気ライン
非常に安く購入させていただきます
それを学生の打差と一緒に分解して作業として逃走して組み立ててそしてもちろん
nht の製作技術を方も沢山あって一緒に対してあげます
まあその時の写真ですが
ここに赤いシャツを着ているきました分は今
メモリーの世界のメモリー外車バイクのジャパンを最長しております
その時のスタッフの皆の最新かやっぱりです
そこで最初に作ったのが
一辺が0.4右です
のトランジスターを作りました始めてね動きましたっ
みんなここでうちの学生対校と不況なんですが
私たちに何も言わない前世個のトランジスターとかって line で送られてくる
部品価格
菩提作り今でも1倍が
山と谷月40年だ
ただチップにキャップしただけないですね
よくは全然超える部分になったん
まあいつもこれを聴いてもらってさあ続けます
それから次に
4にデビューしたのが皆さんご存知のもういいさんが最初にエンデバーで打ち上げ実験
に恋を
ウジュンあげました
そこで宇宙良いの実験を団や大学の満たない
環境医療研究所の先生たちがやってきましたと言う
ボランティアいうだけ時間を作ってないんですが豊田市いては ic ができるところ
だと
で自白本を買ってきていろんな見つけると大きくだって恋がお尻してしまう
一つのチェックで作れません
まあじゃあそれを終始の最初歩テーマの一つにじゃああげましたということでスタート
しました
1992年に年齢バーで成功して2002年に森さんがをこらえて私
ここで作ったんですよねという話をして
まあそんな子たくさんの vip の方々が本格にやって来られましたん
そこで残念たってこういう ic を立ち上げながらやはぎとうは書かないといけない
私が最初にとなって出た成果が
ドンウンにして
初めての国際会議でアメリカでワイオミング
ジャッツもコーンという
売ってたんですけど
そこに8分に行くことになったんですが今日空日は最悪を糧に何が最悪だったといい
ますと
初めて編めるようには
サンフランシスコで1羽へ
次の木村と0値ティ e ですね引いて駅にき1尾の
ジャクソン交易の事項
でお湯でしたので私と中野先生はよく一緒に食べをすると肌4月6赤羽先生と話して
いると
45本時もレストラン者ポイントだから行こう
力て飛行犬ぶー
トンネルです
先生国公医政寛実はありましたよね
急いでカウンターに行っても綺麗な女性が
いうリストアップ
えっということで私の発表は次だけの
2番目
だから先生は電話して最後に生まれて前でも私最初のつかんだから計画通り発表したい
こうしてますと前のオットセイが一生懸命キーボードを叩いて調べているんです
こっちが必死になっていろいろ入っていると思うんですか
一つの方が祝いとトレンド州の
ii 山ホールに行って
そこからレンタカー書いてロッキー3件を超える
誰であればいけます
存在予定は全然こっちしてませんよで勉強に思って待って
抑え挨拶
だから設定が日本の便器シオサイトに出てわれ
それを言ったら
が貸してくれたんですよね運用
貸してくれなかったらどうなってたんだろうって
その後思いましたけどもとりあえず買っ
はそれからこんな話をしだすと1時間がかかります
今日は18分しか第二0
その間アメリカの人にいろいろ助けて偶然
弾キラキララッキーの誕生
で
8日間の12時過ぎにホテルつきました
その辺お話をしたいんですがドライブ
真っ黒なんですねぇー
ぬばけがぞ
ラバーゼ芝もこれは印判 c 強化は霊媒所
伝えてそこ言葉か知ってですねフィスって誰もこのような彼につかりは今センターは外
会社に正できるようにつきました次は黄笠
気分息のままイモトはありませんか
医師らはいいか jr のせい
いません
ゆがめ
もう発表の時間調整をホテルやいった実感があったそこでしようと思ってたんですが
そんなん全然となっている
を言うから12時間帯とか食べとりあえ
阿蘇多少がいいぎっ
ここにいるいうだけで中ですね神ゲー
国内の
が会で発表するよずっともオーナーでここ私がしゃべってるよりのきっとボーダーが出
るっ
でも時間は折らないといけたいっ
ok 多かった多い
もうあとは
覚えてませんかも一生懸命
プレゼンスということで
その後東京工業大学古川先生が
企業の方々に御の引率といっぱいあって
医師はこの
今日よかっ手を染めてい
これ
苦労の被害があったということでその後は全館かれたレンタカーだから
不幸へヒーローすと
ドライブしてですね
まあそういうことで
最悪を経験いったわけじゃないんですが
もしそういう事にあったら明らかクリアすればそれはもうあとどんなことをことも怖
ござい
いう本当に
貴重な経験をさせてくらい
それから
不可能を可能にしようば彼の偉業というか難しくても2回勉強生後は熱意を持って若く
てもわたり
変馬体は出てきますよ
これが14年間最初に
実験をしていたんですが
その中で14年目には担当たい装置はだんだん多くだって高性能化していい僕が入って
くる
そのよさんだけど
で中川先生がそれを言う
で私たち使うのだとしてはそれを入れて込ん貸さないだろう
入れて動かすの場所が
プリンロールを
狭いということで私はいろいろ増いくというものですが陰部を海底下共編でインター私
取り囲んで
お前は何でそんな事を言う
だから先生はいいといった反対はしてないんですけど
使うためにはこういうところが必要ですよ説明している
全裸川世線で終わったーいそれで行けるという ok をもらいました球
それで私は ok を出さ
いろいろカーして大学をどっかひどいで青改装して入れる
青施設課長だけは私の
浴衣前世ということです
ですか強打で電話文科省も関係しているのでもされ
hey
はいっ
はいとか言って帰っ先生改造って言ったらどんな新しい立てたてませんって言ってます
よ
今あげるですねこそ
ということで本格的な大機能デバイス研究室が
だとというのもやはりを信じに渡り合って二つ私は思うんですが
が国にあるようにプラニーズだったらいろんなセンサーと ic を一緒した
ぽりじゅあるなチップを開発していく
はその中でとりあえずプロ
ic の上に
細胞の
神経そのため2 d pro 最後で中3黒
速力実際と千里子と針ロプランチェスター立てて買ってっ
かかる脳がは代替提案して皆に
以上起業しなことばっかし振り返して
開発してというのも今若い先生がこれを引き継ぎ研究されておりますけれどもそういう
端からじゃあ今度は
新年国だまあという
ことですが
まーたということはたては当然それおいしいよね
人間の3月
萃香熱意
それを研究実はだしているとかせな靴研究費ももいい
シュッとたちもあれば悪いとしてい
何度かそのイージーだけ音などが鳴らない
いろんな
可能性を探りました
ちょうど今ドキながら先生がですね一緒にやってた
生まれたけど水脈で突如たくなる私を方生かされたかと
それでどうやってこれを課題を解決する
文科省へ説明し
あるいは
あっ大学にはベンチャー3でするはこれはとりーというものがあっ
それには21人
じゃあうちに行いたとこないんですねそうしてました翻訳を出してを学会です
きてますと電話ある大学の先生かでを
整理しちゃって道には便キャビネットた分の申請の用紙がきまして
先生すみませんファックスで追ってくださいとポップスを言ってもらって
大学を持っているとじゃあそれ本当に金に書いたんを開いた人
もう箇所いった僕であるようにあったの大学が放送が怒ってもうすでに村ラップをやっ
ているんですと
これは悪い大学農家ので大学の価格差
でもこっちはもう1団体ご説明に入ってます
くださいん
これで
ガッツボブですね
こと貼ったらそれもその後色
実現する場でつなんでもかかります
ということで10年かかったんですけれども私は
これが一番の成果だ私ポイントね
あとはこれをもとに
やっていけば建物でクリーンルームを
東工大を元総長先生からこれ警部がたい
や不眠といいんじゃない
装置はお金があればどこでも買え
だけどそれを学生の人たちみんな結構動かして実際ものができる
こういう脳幹をボスてるっていうと受け入れるか
この言葉は非常にうれしかった
ということで罪悪を家庭
まあ真剣にやるの大量に使う飽きられない
まあこういうことをやりながら
本学の nsi 五洋を渡っていて
わっ一応悪いですからこの後大変なせいかあるんですよこれはお豆とまぁこれはいまし
た
まあその一つは du 実に昼
センターもお得されてい
素晴らしい研究の拡大がある二行そうさせたと言って拡大や頭が苦境が薪炭するほど
これ取れの葛藤をどうしよう
うちは2と思っております
はそれはみんなと
議論していろいろ愛でを院展ジェンという間選手
今で言う人からいろんな尿を採ってネット2次で落ち浴びお正
10だるま椅子そういう話ください
スタートしその後グローバル仕様に泊まったやにゃんですが
メディアが拠点といいなし8位というのはかっこいい
お水まあそういう日やだやハオ君です
だけど予算はを買います
最後うちは取りません
東海地区でおうち
電場
でもそう買ったんだよだというのは最初の構想が非常に広かったから今日から
李暁霞だっ
半分されると b ロードを打ちますよねそう
だからもう内は得意かセンシングで
集中するという印10%減とヒューマン選手
まあ
発表してき屋根馬です
こういう私ストレッサーと後温泉浴衣
まあお湯歌を線とでっ
それが国際会議だ+の利用で会った時に
家を選べるもらって
完璧でダメだったした
らと記者会見で帰っていて
学長道
社会その後研究書おっ
by 地道なその成果が来れるんですけど
そして特にあるようににはいろんな全身リップを頑張って
というか教職員の皆さんで実際に行こう
とっ
間違い上は奪えて言うかを見せるか
今朝によってが行っている
5送っ
最後に研究代表力新授業料膳に15年間いう年間全国の大学で十分なポップ印西市21
便ぬ不採択台北かあかんばっている麻痺熱い歳ですけどパパでるっ
でこの結果を若い人も知って
私は退職しましたけれどもあと頑張っていただきたい
いうことで88番目の大学でスタートしました旅
まあ広いを代表する研究大学まで出したということで味を配らせていただいた伊藤後に
ありがとうございました
はぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]